[Music]
[Applause]
our good buddy Ross Tucker was on the
call for Westwood one last night host of
the Ross Tucker football podcast he
joins us on the program Ross thanks for
joining us I know you're short on sleep
having taken the red eye last night from
Los Angeles how would you sum up the
final two minutes of that game last
night
the movie dan that I've seen so many
times before uh I don't know if it's the
sequel or the trilogy or what you start
to call them after that but it's really
unbelievable Dan because from both sides
after landing in like 40 minutes ago and
uh it's unbelievable how often Patrick
Mahomes and Travis Kelsey do that I mean
I I don't know what the live betting
odds were that they would score a
touchdown on that drive but everybody
and I think and I mean everybody knew
that was going to happen and I think
what's really interesting to me about it
is walking out of that Stadium last
night Dan and seeing the Chargers fans
the Chargers fans just had this look on
their faces like they're they're like a
beaten down bunch in the sense that they
knew it was coming but every time they
get their hope up just a little bit
Herbert those uh the Deep ball to Keenan
Allen and then they throw the touchdown
every time the Chargers get their hopes
up against the Chiefs and then Patrick
Mahomes steals their heart
yeah I I wonder what those odds were in
the uh for the Chiefs scoring a
touchdown because I certainly would have
piled on the Chiefs it was a question of
how they were going to score a touchdown
not if and you start to look at is the
MVP been right in front of us here for
the last month or so we just refused to
acknowledge that
well I think Patrick Holmes is the clear
front runner right now and I think
you're probably right now a lot of
people were starting to say you know
they were saying Josh Allen for a while
until he had those two games with the
red zone interceptions Jalen hurts has
had an awfully awfully good year but
when you look at the stats from homes I
mean he's leading quarterbacks Dan and
pretty much every category and what's so
impressive to me about it is all they
did this off scene was trade away the
best receiver in the NFL I mean I mean
that that's the part that's so
impressive talking with some Chiefs
folks uh coaches before the game they
said you know when they had Tyreke and
Kelsey teams would double both of those
guys
and at times they'd have to go elsewhere
and the other guys they would go to
weren't always able to step up and get
the job done whereas this year they
don't have Tyrique but obviously
Kelsey's been masterful but then all the
other guys right the juju Smith
Schuster's Hardman Sky Moore all those
guys have stepped up in their own way
and made plays when they've been called
upon it's almost like the Holmes has
matured and his progression as a
quarterback and doing a better job of
just spreading the ball around to
wherever the ball is supposed to go
unless he absolutely has to have it
there then it's Travis Kelsey which by
the way I I really I I know Derwin James
is an awesome player it's it's totally
rare what Derwin James can do Dan but I
thought that was a major coaching error
on Brandon Staley on that drive the
entire tribe to put Derwin James man in
the man on Travis Kelsey that is asking
a lot and I could tell you having been
like in New England Dan there's no way
Bill Belichick would have let Travis
kills to do that on that drive there's
no way they would have doubled him
somebody else would have had to beat him
maybe Brandon Staley just has that much
faith in Derwin James but I thought they
did not put James in a position to
succeed you cannot be covering Travis
Kelsey man-to-man in that situation
uh let me go back to what we were
talking about with MVP with Mahomes it
feels like he's you know default to MVP
because we know we can trust him that
he's going to be great in the Chiefs
might be the favorites because it feels
like we know who they are and what they
are week to week it it feels like wow
where did that come from or that team's
a lot better or a lot worse than I
thought it feels like the Chiefs right
now are the best team in football
well there's certainly one of them I
mean obviously the Eagles are still nine
and one you know you know what I said
last night then after the game that I
was thinking about
we all feel the same way about Mahomes
and the Chiefs right
it's actually kind of wild
and he's only won one Super Bowl isn't
it because in in our head we feel like
he's been like an MVP caliber guy for
six years now and they go to the AFC
Championship game every year
and we think you always gets it done and
we have all these memories against the
bills in the playoff game last year
whatever but the reality is he's gotten
the two Super Bowls and he's 1-1 which
I don't know what the point is I'm
making other than maybe what Brady's
done is ridiculous but it just it just
goes to show I guess how hard it really
is because it's hard for my homes to
have played much better than he has so
far in his career and yet he only has
won one of them
we're talking to Ross Tucker CBS
Westwood one color analyst host to the
Ross Tucker football podcast he was on
the call Chargers Chiefs last night I'm
going to play this question and answer
Zach Wilson of the Jets and how you
think this answer will go over in the
locker room with the Jets
that as an offense though I mean when
you guys are only able to score three
points the defense only lets up three
points I mean do you do you feel like
you let the defense down at all
thank you how do you think that's going
to go over that no no you didn't let the
defense down
to me comes across as like insecurity
right like if you're comfortable with
who you are as a player and you're and
you're confident
then when you mess up you own it right
like the smartest people I know admit
the things they don't know the most
successful people like if you screwed up
on the show Dan you'd be like uh because
you know you're dancing you're really
gonna when everyone throw out baby you
screw up
I think Zach Wilson is not confident he
doesn't feel good about who he is or
where his standing is on the team so it
comes across as an insecure response or
a defensive response whereas if he was a
more established player he'd be like
heck yeah I feel bad I think he knows
what people are saying about him and I
think as a result he doesn't want to um
Flame the fire right feed the fire by
saying yes I do feel like I let those
guys down I do feel like the offense did
it's like he's got he's got his Burrs up
and he's ready to defend himself and and
be defiant and sometimes maybe that's
why guys become good players is because
they have that Defiance but no that's
not going to go over real well I mean
imagine being a defensive player in that
locker room you gave up three points the
whole game
and you still lost those guys must be
furious and I've said it for a couple
weeks I feel like
Robert Sala has a decision to make at
some point because at some point it's a
culture thing and you need the players
on the team to trust you and the trust
that you're making the decisions to try
to help them go to the playoffs and win
these games and it's starting to become
painfully obvious that Zach Wilson does
not give them the best chance to win
these games
you have the Giants and the Cowboys on
Thanksgiving
what do you expect considering what just
happened yesterday with these two teams
well first of all I think it's amazing
that Odell Beckham Jr is reportedly
picking between these two teams he
should go to the game I heard what uh
Paulie said earlier he should go to the
game it should be like you don't get the
turkey leg if you win you get the Odell
Beckham Jr
um I I I've never seen the guy is a
marketing genius I've never seen a guy
get this much attention so Tory's ACL on
the circle I my prediction there Dan
will be that this will be the most
ineffectual signing in years I think I
had a torn ACL in the Super Bowl we've
been talking about this for months I
mean it's unbelievable I don't the
Cowboys even have their own marketing
strategy of just keep talking about it
keep talking about it and show him the
power of the brand of the Cowboys I mean
it's I hope I I hope he plays well at
this point because we've been talking
about it so much
um you know that's kind of the beauty of
the NFL like it wouldn't shock me if the
Giants beat the Cowboys on Thursday
the Cowboys just looked like the best
team they just murdered the Vikings
the Giants looked awful they got run
over by the Lions they couldn't do
anything but none of that really matters
when they go inside the white lines on
Thursday now do I think that'll happen
no I think the Cowboys will probably win
the game I think they're the better team
I think they're more talented but that's
kind of the beauty of it is that
um there there is no carryover right
like I saw where the Cowboys now Dan
have the second best Super Bowl odds
it's Kansas City and then the Cowboys
are the three lost Cowboys on the
strength of that performance yesterday
jumped over other teams like the Vikings
like the eagles in terms of the Super
Bowl but nobody cares how good you
looked on November 20th in January it
doesn't really matter other than I guess
giving those guys some confidence of
just how high their ceiling is
great to talk to you safe uh travels
home there and uh have fun on
Thanksgiving
thank you Dan appreciate it that's Ross
Tucker CBS Westwood one color analyst
host of Ross Tucker football podcast and
you can follow him on social media at
rosstucker NFL